こんにちは!
はじめしゃちょーです!
wwwww
どうしょうもねぇ
今アバンティーズの家に来てるんですけども
まぁ、久しぶりだね、ほんとに
久しぶりっすね、はい
1ヶ月ぶりぐらい?
www
なーにが面白いの(笑)
wwwww
っまちょっと、離れてたからさー
時間が空いてたわけよ　俺達の
確かに
距離が離れてるかもしれないし
確かにー
心と心の
心、の距離も離れてるかもしれないわけよ
怖いよねそこは
wwwww
怖いよほんとに
www
近づきたいっすよね
確かに確かに
こういうのがきっかけで、っちゃぅ俺たちの仲が悪くなるかもしれないじゃん
wwwww
俺たちの距離を近づけようというわけで
いや、離れてもさー
距離は離れるけど心は近づくわけよ、綱引きで
そうですね　うん
引くんだよ　引き合うんだよ!
そうですね!(笑)
でも、離れるじゃないですか!?
いや、それは物理的な話だよ!
www
近づくんだよ!やっぱ心が　綱引きをすると
やっぱ今日はちょっとみんなで綱引きをして
心を取り戻そう！1回
というわけで今回輪ゴムを何個か準備しました
これは、何個入り?
75gって表記はやめてほしい
どれぐらいかな?
ま～、やでもちょっと盛っときゃいいんじゃないすか
1000個ぐらいにしとくか
wwwww
1回ちょっと数えるわ
え～!?
めんどくせぇ(笑)
81!
57!
ろくじゅうきゅう
330か
じゃそれが4つあるから、330×4は
1320個の輪ゴムを使って、
輪ゴムを繋げて、
綱引きの綱をつくろう。
(失笑)
あっは(笑)
待って、めんどくねぇ?これぇ
どうする?
ひひはははは(笑)
止めんのぉ!?
こう、まとめてやっちゃえばいいんじゃない
こう、まとめてさ
おぉ～!
っちょ、こぉ通すじゃん。まとめて
こう
ジーニアスだ。
で、また、こうさぁ
こうやんじゃん
でまたこここうさぁ
なるほどぉ!
ねぇやばい、心つながるよこれ
これやばいっしょ
結構バラバラだべ
wwwww
ね、欲張ったらダメだね
欲張ったらキツイわ
いやそれだいぶヤバイ、欲張りボーイじゃん
(笑)欲張りボーイって
すごい量だな、1300本って
すごいよね、これ
減らないんだけど
これ楽しくない!?
楽しいっすぇ
おぉぅらっ!
おぉけぃーーーーぃやぇぃーーーー!!!
ドア#☆%◎
あぁーーーぁあーー!!
うわぁーー!!
%#☆?◎!$&◆
はいというわけで皆さんやってまいりました～
wwwちくしょう
無事、輪ゴム(笑)が
ちっくしょー、おめー(笑)
全部 繋ぎ(笑)終わったんですけどもー(笑)
どうでしょうかこの!
2つの長い輪ゴムを、完成したのでー
この2つを今から合体させてー、本番用の縄を作ります
ここからどうつなげるかだよ、問題は
そこですよねー
なんも考えてなかった
あっ!待って俺手錠買ったわ
たまたま手錠を買ってたので、これで、ちょ繋ぎましょう
これやばい
っしー
これ、ガチモンのっ、っその
公式、試合用のやつじゃん
wwww
どうやってこれ、ざっ、こう、す、あんれすんの　あの、螺旋状に
無理!
え、できるよ!
俺が乗ってさぁ
こう
wwwww
ほらほらほら!
おっ!
おぉ～
おぉおぉ～!　きたきた!
おぉ～、マジか
なんかあんまかっこよくないんだよな
wwwww
やばいよ、これ、ほら!
あっ、すごいすごいすごい
やばいよ!
これが正しいやり方なんだ(笑)
お、きたんじゃん!?　ほら!
ゅ、ゃ、
ほらほらほら
できたよ!
っげ!
できたできた
できた!
無事、輪ゴムで綱ができたので
実際に、綱引きをして遊んでみましょう!!
www　(拍手)
ルールは、あの普通の綱引きと一緒で
伸ばしてー、この線を
越えたら
越えるとぉ、負け　っていう、ルール
やっていきましょう
はい
リクオは審判です
痛ッ!!
グっと、パ!!
wwwww
ぃよーーい
だーーー!!!
だあぁあーーーー!!!!!
わーー!!
いけるぞ!!　いけるぞ!
いける!!
マジかやばい!
え、やばい
マジやばい!!!
マジいける!!
あ、やばい!!!
なんか脚がすごい下になってんだ(笑)
あぁーーーぁい!!!!
いっ、そこやだ!!
あぁー!!　あーい!!!
いっ、そこやだぁ!!!
あぁーーーー!!!
待って!…手が痛い
あーーーー!!!!!
っあぁ!!
バカ野郎!!
なんてーはんし
バカ!!
%#☆?◎!$&◆
っおほぉ
あ゛ーーーー!!!!!
1回落ち着きましょ、落ち着きましょ、落ち着きましょ…
ぅいよっしゃあ!!!
あ゛ーーーー!!!!!
あぁ!　あ、あ、ぁ、ぁ、ぁ、あ、あ、あ
ああぁぁぁああ!!!　痛ッッ!!!
痛ッ!　いっったぁ!!!
マジか!!!!
くっっそ!!
…コードギアス。